The physics we’re going to talk about today
has SAVED your life.
Whenever you step into a building, or walk
across a bridge --
THIS is the science that keeps the building STANDING, the bridge STABLE, and you ALIVE.
It’s STATICS -- the study of how objects
behave, when they are NOT accelerating.
Whether that means they’re standing completely still, or moving at a CONSTANT velocity.
Statics can tell you a lot about the way things
behave, when you’re trying to balance them,
or when they’re being COMPRESSED or STRETCHED.
So engineers use statics for things like...figuring
out where a building’s supports should go,
and how MANY of them there should be...Or
what type of bridge design would work BEST
to cross that river in town.
You can use it, too -- say...the next time
you climb a ladder.
If you do, you’ll find that, even though an object may not be moving, there are still, all kinds of things affecting it.
Like stress, and strain
and pressure.
So who knows? Today’s episode may someday,
save your life!
[Theme Music]
Objects that aren’t accelerating are said
to be in EQUILIBRIUM, a concept that we’ve touched on before.
It means that there can be forces ON an
object, but there can’t be NET forces on it.
Otherwise, that net force m, would make
the object accelerate.
Torque affects equilibrium too, since an object
in equilibrium, can’t have rotational acceleration, either.
So again, there can be torques on an object in equilibrium, but there can’t be NET torques on it.
In other words, the net torques must be equal to zero.
All of this means that for an object to be in equilibrium, all the forces AND torques on it have to balance out.
A classic example of forces and torques cancelling
each other out, is a ladder leaning against a wall.
The ladder isn’t accelerating -- or even
moving -- so it must be in equilibrium.
But, how much force is there on the ladder,
from both the wall and the floor?
That's pretty easy to figure out!
Let’s say we know that the bottom of the
ladder is 3m from the wall, the top of the
ladder is 4m from the floor, the ladder itself
is 5m long, and it has a mass of 10kg.
The first thing we gotta do is draw a free-body
diagram.
First, the force of gravity, mg, is pulling
down, on the center of the ladder.
And the force from the wall has only one component
-- it’s pushing sideways on the ladder.
Meanwhile, the force from the floor has
two components:
one pushing UP on the ladder,
equal and opposite to the force of gravity
and one pushing on the ladder toward the wall, equal and opposite to the force FROM the wall.
Let’s talk about the force from the wall
first.
We don’t know how strong it is. But we can figure that out, by thinking about the torques acting on the ladder.
The ladder isn’t rotating, so any torques
on it have to add up to zero.
And we know from our previous lessons that torque is caused by a force applied at a distance from an axis.
So, if we choose the point where the ladder
touches the floor as our axis,
we can see that there are two forces
applying a torque to the ladder.
In this case, the ladder is leaning to the
RIGHT to meet the wall, so the force of gravity
is applying a clockwise torque.
And the force from the wall is applying a
counterclockwise torque.
And we know that both of those torques equal each other, because the net torque on the ladder is zero.
The torque from gravity is equal to the ladder’s
weight, times the perpendicular distance from
our axis to the center of the ladder -- and
that’s 147 Newton meters.
Meaning that the torque from the WALL is also
147 Newton meters, in the opposite direction.
Divide that by the vertical distance from where the ladder hits the wall to our axis of rotation,
and we get 36.8 Newtons: the
force from the wall on the ladder.
That’s half of the problem done!
But what about the force on the ladder from
the floor?
Like we said, there are two components of
the force from the floor: horizontal and vertical.
The horizontal component will be equal to
the force from the wall -- so, 36.8 Newtons.
And the vertical component will be equal to
the ladder’s weight -- so, 98 Newtons.
We’ve already talked about how to find the
total magnitude of a force from its components
-- you square the components, add the results,
then take the square root of that number.
Meaning that the total force from the floor
on the ladder is 105 Newtons.
So, once you know that an object’s in equilibrium,
you can use that fact to find the forces and torques acting on it.
That’s important, because those forces can
affect the object’s shape -- and maybe even break it.
That’s why one of the main questions that
engineers consider is:
When I apply a force to this thing, what will
happen to it?
And generally, whatever happens will be one
of three main things:
First, you can apply just enough force that
the object will either stretch or compress,
but still spring back -- in that case, the
force is in a range known as the material’s elastic zone.
But if you apply a little too much force,
the object might become permanently deformed
-- meaning, the force has reached what’s
called the plastic zone.
And apply WAY too much force, and you’ll get to the breaking point -- otherwise known as fracture.
Ideally, engineers want to make sure that the objects they use to build things, like support beams,
stay within the range of Option
Number One: the elastic zone.
Often, they’ll also want to know how an object’s shape changes based on the amount of force that’s being applied to it.
And the amount that an object stretches or
compresses depends on a few different factors:
First, there’s the original length of the object. The longer it is, the more it will stretch or compress.
The strength of the applied force also matters.
More force means more stretching or compressing.
Then there’s the area of a cross-section
of this object.
Basically, the thicker it is, the less it will STRETCH or compress.
Finally, there’s the type of material itself.
Wood, steel, aluminum, granite --
they’re all going to have different amounts of elasticity.
That’s why engineers use something called Young’s modulus.
It’s a number, represented by a capital E,
that tells you how hard it is to stretch or compress a given material, based on that material’s stiffness.
The higher Young’s modulus is, for a certain
material, the less ELASTIC it is.
And all of these factors combine into one
equation.
It might look kind of messy, but this equation
is just saying that the change in length of
something that’s being stretched or compressed
depends on:
its original length, the force you apply,
its cross-sectional area, and Young’s modulus.
And we can use this equation to help define a couple of terms that engineers use a lot: stress and strain.
Now, these aren’t the same as the feelings you get the night before a huge exam.
Instead, stress is the force on an object,
divided by its cross-sectional area --
basically, that F over A term.
And strain is the object’s change in length,
divided by its original length.
This equation, and Young’s modulus, apply
for two types of stress:
‘tensile stress’, which stretches objects out,
and ‘compressive stress’, which compresses them.
But sometimes the forces you apply to objects
aren’t just compressing or stretching.
For example: you could also apply what’s
known as shear stress.
Maybe you’ve done this before:
Say there’s a really thick book laying on a table -- say, Game of Thrones or a big dictionary.
If you push the top of the book parallel to the table, the pages will all sort of slide over each other.
Where before you had a nice rectangular-looking
book, now you have more of a … parallelogram.
The sliding happens because you’re
applying a force to the top of the book,
while the table applies an equal and opposite force to the bottom.
That’s shear stress.
And the way an object deforms under shear
stress depends on the same kinds of factors
that are involved when you compress or stretch
something.
Like, if the original length were longer -- meaning you had a thicker, taller book: That would mean more sliding.
More force? More sliding.
More area perpendicular to the force -- in
other words, a book with bigger pages? Less sliding.
And then there’s the inherent slidy-ness
of the material, that the object is made of,
which we call the shear modulus.
Just like Young’s modulus, the shear
modulus is different for every material,
and is just a number, represented by a capital-G.
The higher its shear modulus, the less the
object will deform.
Put all those factors together, and you get
an equation that should look very familiar.
It’s just like the equation we had before,
for stretching and compressing.
The only differences are that the original
length, area, and change in length
represent different parts of the object,
and that we use a different modulus.
But we have one last type of shape-change
to consider: shrinking!
This is what happens if you apply a force to all the parts of an object at once -- say, by putting it in water.
The same factors affect the shape change here,
too.
The more volume the object originally had,
the more it’ll shrink --
In other words, the more its volume will change.
When we’re talking about something submerged in a fluid, we give a different name to the force divided by area.
And instead of stress,
we call it pressure.
And the more pressure you apply to an object,
the more it will shrink.
Finally, some materials are more resistant
to changes in volume --
and that stiffness is measured by the bulk modulus, represented by a capital-B.
Combined, these factors form an equation you
can use to predict how much an object will shrink.
So now you know the three main ways that forces
affect an object’s shape:
changing its length -- through tensile and
compressive stress,
deforming it through shear stress,
and changing its volume through pressure.
And hopefully, now you also have a better understanding of all the thought that goes into making sure buildings and bridges stay up.
Today, you learned that the net force and torque on an object in equilibrium, must equal zero,
and you saw how you can use that fact
to calculate individual forces and torques.
We also talked about the way objects deform under tensile, compressive, and shear stress, as well as pressure.
Crash Course Physics is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios. You can head over
to their channel to check out amazing shows
like Deep Look, The Good Stuff, and PBS Space Time.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these amazing people and
our equally amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.